I've spoken to a lot of top tier
creators that have tens of millions of
followers on Tick Tock they're wondering
if this is another fine moment not
because the engagement's going down but
because the monetization is not going up
is Tick Tock going to try to really
start competing with YouTube because I'm
not really seeing that happen in
practice my message would be who cares
and what I mean by that would be what's
the bigger Diversified business You're
Building away from
on monetization if meta sends me a check
if Tick Tock sends me a check I'm
grateful but the bigger question is what
else are you doing that's not dependent
upon the platforms